Putin slams us and Bill Clinton for
deceiving Russia over NATO membership as
he trashes Biden Praises Trump and warns
there no there's no stopping his
supersonic missile system this is
interesting Putin says that Bill Clinton
offered Russia a place in NATO but was
overruled by his staff so basically what
happens is Putin was like look in the
90s I meet with Bill Clinton and there's
pictures of it Tucker posts picture
includes pictures in the interview and I
said look if Russia wants to join NATO
would that be possible and Bill Clinton
said I think so yeah and then comes back
later that night for dinner or whatever
I think that's what he said and Clinton
says you know we talked about it it's
not going to happen Putin said the
reason was the US applies pressure on
all the NATO member states and they vote
the way the US wants having some a
nation as powerful as Russia as large
would mean that US influence would be
compromised to a certain degree within
NATO